Lucia: 如果不是如果
Lucia: If it wasn't for ifs
Lucia: 有一些需要和谐的词汇的话
Lucia: and needing to censor some words
Lucia: 你们会马掉吗
Lucia: would you guys beep them?
Lucia: 比如说f word这些的
Lucia: Like the f-word and stuff
Jake:不会吧
Jake: Probably not
Lucia: 啊这样吗
Lucia: Oh, really?
Jake:这不管了管不了这么多
Jake: We don't really care about that much
Alice: 采集一下牡丹
Alice: Let's gather some peonies
Lucia: got feelings they only hear you say
Lucia: Got feelings they only hear you say
Alice: 漂亮好喜欢
Alice: Beautiful, I love it
Alice: 哦开的真好
Alice: Oh, they bloomed so well
Jake: 原来我有一个帽子
Jake: Turns out I have a hat
Jake: 我也觉得我没有戴帽子
Jake: I thought I wasn't wearing one
Jake: 结果是有帽子
Jake: But I actually have a hat
Lucia: 其实你也可以在上面再待一个
Lucia: You could actually wear another one on top
Tasha: 你摄像头不带吗
Tasha: Aren't you bringing your camera?
Jake:戴
Jake: I am
Jake: 他总共能录的不久
Jake: It can only record for a short time
Lucia: 哦这个地方好像北大
Lucia: Oh, this place looks like Peking University
Lucia: 救命哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Help, hahaha
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈哈确实
Jake: Hahaha, indeed
Alice: 未名湖呃
Alice: Weiming Lake, uh
Lucia: 对啊那个塔也很像伯牙塔
Lucia: Yeah, that tower looks like Boya Tower
Alice: 通州分湖
Alice: Tongzhou Branch Lake
Lucia: 比伯牙塔那个塔尖高一点
Lucia: The spire is a bit taller than Boya Tower
Jake: 对通州分塔通州分塔
Jake: Yeah, Tongzhou Branch Tower, Tongzhou Branch Tower
Alice: 这是芬塔哈哈
Alice: This is the Branch Tower, haha
Jake: 通州分塔
Jake: Tongzhou Branch Tower
Jake: 没什么人
Jake: There's hardly anyone here
Jake: 所以很适合跳舞
Jake: So it's great for dancing
Alice: 真的跳舞
Alice: Really dancing
Jake: 有道理吧
Jake: Makes sense, right?
Tasha: 你也跳一跳你就知道了
Tasha: You should try dancing and you'll see
Lucia: 这种剪辑出来很像抖音上那种尬舞
Lucia: This kind of editing makes it look like those awkward dances on TikTok
Lucia: 就是我说那种突然开始跳舞的那种
Lucia: You know, the ones where they suddenly start dancing
Jake: 啊啊啊是
Jake: Ah, yes
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice: 有小鱼好多
Alice: There are so many small fish
Alice: 啊小鱼苗
Alice: Ah, baby fish
Alice: 好啥呀
Alice: What's good?
Tasha: 好啥
Tasha: What's good?
Alice: 好多啊
Alice: A lot!
Jake: 哪了
Jake: Where?
Alice: 就是那种特别小的
Alice: Those tiny ones.
Alice: 很多然后那种
Alice: There are so many.
Jake: 在蹦跶是吧
Jake: Are they jumping?
Lucia: 小锦鲤吗
Lucia: Are they little koi fish?
Alice: 对对对然后还有那种有颜色的
Alice: Yeah, yeah, and they're colorful too.
Jake: 还小王八
Jake: And little turtles.
Jake: 我看到了
Jake: I saw them.
Lucia: 哎我看到了
Lucia: Oh, I saw them too.
Alice: 那个金黄色的
Alice: The golden ones.
Jake: 对小王八小鱼
Jake: Yeah, little turtles and fish.
Alice: 然后这些小小的全是特别小的鱼苗
Alice: And all these tiny, tiny fish fry.
Lucia: 哈哈为什么不是小乌龟
Lucia: Haha, why not little turtles?
Alice: 好多好多
Alice: So many, so many.
Alice: 小王八是一种
Alice: Little turtles are one kind.
Lucia: 王八和乌龟是一种吗
Lucia: Are turtles and tortoises the same?
Lucia: 王八是甲鱼还是什么
Lucia: Is a turtle a kind of softshell turtle or what?
Jake: 应该是哦
Jake: Maybe, I don't know.
Jake: 是吗我也不知道
Jake: Is it? I have no idea.
Lucia: 我不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia: 好吧那我们就姑且认为是同一种吧
Lucia: Okay, let's just assume they're the same.
Jake: 对对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 这面好多鱼啊
Lucia: There are so many fish here.
Alice: 好多好多
Alice: So many, so many.
Lucia: 好多人啊哈哈
Lucia: So many people, haha.
Jake: 是说钓鱼啦钓
Jake: They're talking about fishing.
Jake: 鼓掌有什么用
Jake: What's the point of clapping?
Jake: 鼓掌有什么用啊
Katrina:  哎有小鱼在吃
Katrina: Oh, there's a fish eating.
Jake: 鱼鱼鱼它鱼它有耳朵是吗
Jake: Fish, fish, do fish have ears?
Jake: 哦这么个音波是吧
Jake: Oh, it's like sound waves, right?
Katrina:  哎呦很好
Katrina: Oh, very good.
Katrina:  这个抛的很准
Katrina: That throw was very accurate.
Shure:  这素材够用吧
Shure: Is this footage enough?
Katrina:  这老北京鱼翅达美乐呀
Katrina: This is like old Beijing's fish fin delicacy.
Shure:  全吞了
Shure: They swallowed it whole.
Shure:  那叫一个
Shure: That's called a...
Alice: 地地地地地道
Alice: Beep beep beep beep beep
Jake: 呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehe
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Shure:  天嘀嗒地嘀嗒滴答滴滴答
Shure: The sky goes tick tock tick tock tick tock tick tick tock
Shure:  滴滴答滴滴答
Shure: Tick tick tock tick tick tock
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha
Jake: 和鱼一起吃
Jake: Eat it with the fish
Katrina:  开吃才走两步
Katrina: Just started eating and already took two steps
Alice: 小鱼苗哎
Alice: Little fish fry
Alice: 还不吃挑食吗
Alice: Not eating, being picky?
Tasha: 太大了
Tasha: It's too big
Tasha: 可恶污染海洋了哈哈
Tasha: Damn, it's polluting the ocean, haha
Alice: 你看那有一个逆流而上的鱼
Alice: Look, there's a fish swimming upstream
Alice: 海风往这边吹
Alice: The sea breeze is blowing this way
Alice: 他非得往那边游
Alice: Yet it's swimming that way
Alice: 他还游不动
Alice: And it can't swim
Tasha: 这离上岸得多远啊
Tasha: How far is it from the shore?
Alice: 哈哈哈不如随波逐流吧
Alice: Hahaha, might as well go with the flow
Tasha: 我的妈呀
Tasha: Oh my god
Tasha: 我真不敢想
Tasha: I can't even imagine
Alice: 哈哈还近一点
Alice: Haha, a bit closer
Katrina:  啊人类
Katrina: Ah, humans
Jake: 是是是你也很特殊
Jake: Yes, yes, you're special too
Katrina:  这就是AI永远无法取取代人类的原因
Katrina: That's why AI can never fully replace humans
Lucia: 虽然我知道
Lucia: Even though I know
Lucia: 经济学家也老假设人类是理性人
Lucia: Economists always assume humans are rational
Katrina:  因为人类总会做一些莫名其妙的行为
Katrina: Because humans always do inexplicable things
Katrina:  这就是人类
Katrina: That's humanity
Jake: 局部是有逻辑的好吧
Jake: There's some logic in parts, okay?
Alice: AI无法理解的
Alice: AI can't understand that
Jake: 局部上是有
Jake: There's logic in parts
Jake: 就是你扔出去
Jake: Like when you throw it out
Alice: 超多小小小小小鱼苗
Alice: So many tiny tiny tiny fish fry
Jake: 然后鱼吃披萨
Jake: And then the fish eats pizza
Lucia: 嗯啊那么小的也有竟然
Lucia: Hmm, even such tiny ones exist, surprisingly
Jake: 对这个是合理的
Jake: Yes, this makes sense
Jake: 然后你看到鱼真披萨
Jake: And then you see the fish actually eating pizza
Alice: 对就超级超级小的
Alice: Yeah, super super tiny ones
Jake: 这个多少是有一点点过去了
Jake: This is a little bit over the top
Katrina:  yes
Katrina: Yes.
Jake: 虽然不多
Jake: Although not much.
Jake: 这些鱼应该什么都吃
Jake: These fish should eat anything.
Jake: 公园里的鱼都是杂食类的鱼
Jake: The fish in the park are all omnivores.
Jake: 鱼肉会吃吗
Jake: Do they eat fish meat?
Jake: 有应该会
Jake: They probably do.
Jake: 应该他们会互相吃
Jake: They might eat each other.
Shure:  废话我们刚刚看了那个
Shure: Obviously, we just saw that.
Lucia: 大鱼吃小鱼是吧
Lucia: Big fish eat little fish, right?
Shure:  发现海里鱼都是在吃自己的东西
Shure: We found that in the sea, fish are always eating their own kind.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  然后评论难道猪能在海里吗哈哈哈
Shure: Then someone commented, "Can pigs live in the sea?" Haha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice: 颐和园的大雁都还挑食呢
Alice: Even the geese in Summer Palace are picky eaters.
Jake: 这都吃完了
Jake: They ate all of it.
Jake: 哈哈哈这都吃完了这个
Jake: Haha, they finished all of this.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice: 什么都吃
Alice: They'll eat anything.
Shure:  啊拿多累啊
Shure: Ah, that's so tiring to carry.
Lucia: 还有一块呢
Lucia: There's still a piece left.
Tasha: 在湖边喂喂鱼
Tasha: Feeding fish by the lake.
Jake: 喂人喂鱼
Jake: Feeding people, feeding fish.
Tasha: 如果去海滩边就会去喂薯条喂人
Tasha: If you go to the beach, you feed fries to people.
Shure:  外边外边
Shure: Outside, outside.
Shure:  自己画的
Shure: Drawn by yourself.
Jake: 对啊一会要有海鸥怎么办
Jake: Yeah, what if there are seagulls later?
Jake: 还有东西喂吗
Jake: Do we still have food for them?
Tasha: 麦当劳整点薯条
Tasha: Get some fries from McDonald's.
Lucia: 火腿还有点渣
Lucia: There's still some ham left.
Alice: 海鸥找点薯条喂他
Alice: Get some fries to feed the seagulls.
Lucia: 去码头整点薯条
Lucia: Go to the dock and get some fries.
Jake: 还有点鸡肉
Jake: There's still some chicken.
Jake: 可以给他留着
Jake: We can save it for them.
Jake: 这个可以扔一下哦还
Jake: We can throw this, oh, there's more.
Jake: 有一盒好
Jake: There's a box left.
Lucia: 啊哈哈哈哈抛洒
Lucia: Ahahaha, scatter it around.
Jake: 哦哦有存货
Jake: Oh, we have reserves.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Jake: 骨灰哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Ashes, hahaha.
Lucia: 披萨也可以算是种面子的骨灰是吧
Lucia: Pizza can also be considered as some kind of ashes, right?
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Mm, yeah.
Jake: 对小码头
Jake: Yeah, the little pier.
Jake: 这叫什么胡啊
Jake: What's this lake called?
Jake: 有名字吗
Jake: Does it have a name?
Alice: 未名湖
Alice: Unnamed Lake.
Lucia: 未名湖
Lucia: Unnamed Lake.
Jake: 好哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Alright, hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina:  哎呀又疑惑了哈哈
Katrina: Oh man, I'm confused again, haha.
Tasha: 难道是我扔的不够远吗
Tasha: Is it because I didn't throw it far enough?
Lucia: 用AI识图识别这一块儿为北大是吗
Lucia: Using AI to recognize this place as Peking University, right?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Mm.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 这边可以预测哪只鱼可以吃得到
Jake: Over here you can predict which fish will get to eat.
Tasha: 我知道如果抢的话就会吃的香
Tasha: I know if I snatch it, it'll taste better.
Tasha: 哈哈你看我的在那后面就不是吃
Tasha: Haha, look, mine isn't eating at the back.
Lucia: 这么神奇
Lucia: That's amazing.
Tasha: 必须要抢才行
Tasha: You have to snatch it to work.
Shure:  你想往哪我就能过了
Shure:  看那边去了
Tasha: 哇太小了
Tasha: 他们不吃
Tasha: 你看开始抢着开始吃了
Katrina:  问一下AI那是活的
Shure:  那是活的吗
Jake: 啊还有死的呀
Shure:  那是条大海鱼
Katrina:  嗯
Lucia: 那是鱼吧
Jake: 那那个
Jake: 就那漂着的吗
Katrina:  嗯
Jake: 哎呦我去
Jake: 这风有点大
Jake: 试试
Alice: 哎什么掉了
Lucia: 那个翻滚的声音
Shure:  啊
Tasha: 你的手链吗
Tasha: Your bracelet?
Tasha: 他的手链断了
Tasha: His bracelet broke.
Alice: 真的假的
Alice: Really?
Katrina:  完了被女朋友骂死
Katrina: Oh no, his girlfriend is going to be so mad.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 掉哪去了
Jake: Where did it fall?
Tasha: 掉到湖里了
Tasha: It fell into the lake.
Alice: 未名湖里
Alice: In Weiming Lake.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 掉未名湖了
Jake: It fell into Weiming Lake?
Jake: 他自己应该记得吧
Jake: He should remember where it fell, right?
Tasha: 记录下来了
Tasha: It’s recorded.
Katrina:  我的眼镜应该看到了
Katrina: My glasses probably saw it.
Jake: 你自己也记了
Jake: You remembered it too.
Shure:  没救了
Shure: It's hopeless.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  滑动摩擦力太小了
Katrina: The sliding friction is too low.
Alice: 好像也不是很深
Alice: It doesn’t seem very deep.
Alice: 要不提供点珍贵素材
Alice: Maybe we could get some valuable footage.
Lucia: 人类早期下水捕鱼素材
Lucia: Early human fishing footage.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Sure.
Shure:  这怎么就剩鱼头了呢
Shure: Why is there only a fish head left?
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake: 呃应该是被吃了嗯
Jake: Uh, it was probably eaten, yeah.
Tasha: 应该是被大鱼吃小鱼的时候吃掉了
Tasha: Probably got eaten by a bigger fish.
Tasha: 那头鱼不喜欢吃鱼头
Tasha: That fish doesn’t like eating fish heads.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice: 他应该吃鱼身子吧
Alice: It probably ate the body, not the head.
Alice: 他不吃鱼头
Alice: It doesn't eat fish heads.
Jake: 是鱼头没什么肉不好吃
Jake: Yeah, fish heads don't have much meat, not tasty.
Katrina:  准备好回去下跪吧搓衣板
Katrina: Get ready to kneel on a washboard when you get back.
Alice: 我靠真是鱼
Alice: Oh my gosh, it’s really a fish.
Jake: 或者是别的一些生物
Jake: Or it could be some other creature.
Jake: NPU那边有水獭
Jake: There are otters near NPU.
Jake: 水獭吃鱼
Jake: Otters eat fish.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 有什么奇怪景象吗
Lucia: Any strange sightings?
Jake: 吃一半就丢路边
Jake: They eat half and leave the rest by the road.
Lucia: 让我的让我的眼睛也看一看哈哈
Lucia: Let me take a look, let me take a look too, haha.
Alice: 让我的眼睛也看一看
Alice: Let me take a look too.
Tasha: 哎有一头牛奶鱼
Tasha: Hey, there's a milkfish.
Alice: 你看那看见没
Alice: Look at that, did you see it?
Alice: 鱼面已经泡发白了
Alice: The fish noodles have turned white.
Alice: 那个鱼的眼睛睁的贼大
Alice: The fish's eyes are so big.
Lucia: 好可怕
Lucia: So scary.
Alice: 你要捞一下吗
Alice: Do you want to scoop it out?
Lucia: 好可怕
Lucia: So scary.
Alice: 找个棍上哪捞去啊
Alice: Where to find a stick to scoop it?
Shure: 我上哪捞去啊
Shure: Where do I scoop it?
Alice: 大概在哪个位置呢
Alice: About where is it?
Alice: 这一片吧
Alice: Around here, right?
Shure: 没事承认错误吧
Shure: Never mind, just admit it.
Jake: 你问问问问有没有那大网子是吧
Jake: Ask if there's a big net, right?
Shure: 不用捞没事
Shure: No need to scoop, it's fine.
Jake: 在哪啊沉进去了
Jake: Where is it? It sank.
Shure: 那肯定沉进去了
Shure: It definitely sank.
Jake: 那一片是吧
Jake: Over there, right?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake: 嗯吼
Jake: Uh-huh.
Jake: 跟鱼头在一块差不多
Jake: It's near the fish head, right?
Tasha: 就在鱼头附近如何
Tasha: How about around the fish head?
Jake: 让鱼头看看让鱼头看看
Jake: Let the fish head take a look.
Jake: 去下一个景点
Jake: Let's go to the next spot.
Jake: 这是什么景点
Jake: What's this spot?
Tasha: 湖边喂鱼景点
Tasha: The lakeside fish feeding spot.
Jake: 这叫什么
Jake: What's it called?
Shure:  差不多
Shure: Pretty much.
Alice: 说明他完成了他的使命
Alice: It means he completed his mission.
Alice: 帮你躲过一灾
Alice: Helped you avoid a disaster.
Tasha: 下一个清水平台区吧
Tasha: Next, let's go to the clear water platform area.
Tasha: 下一个区
Tasha: The next area.
其他人：是一个珠子的残骸吗
Others: Is that a bead's remnant?
Shure:  有一个能交代就行
Shure: As long as we have one to account for.
Tasha: 把这一个
Tasha: Take this one.
Tasha: 然后掉掉成项链
Tasha: And then turn it into a necklace.
Jake: 啊这什么东西
Jake: What's this thing?
Katrina:  真的吗那是散开了
Katrina: Really? It's scattered.
Lucia: 还有一个珠子
Lucia: There's another bead.
Jake: 在地上
Jake: On the ground
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Shure:  应该是我这个东西他他压的
Shure: It should be this thing of mine that's pressing it down
Alice: 啊，甩出去
Alice: Ah
Katrina:  我当时特别害怕你把眼镜甩出去了
Katrina: I was really scared you'd throw your glasses away
Katrina:  我说完了
Katrina: I was like, oh no
Alice: 看来捞不出来了
Alice: Looks like we can't fish it out
Alice: 他竟然散的话只剩珠子吧里面
Alice: If it's scattered, there should only be beads inside
Katrina:  那这一个串一下戴
Katrina: Then you can wear this one
Katrina:  戴成项链吗
Katrina: Wear it as a necklace?
Katrina:  我心永在
Katrina: My heart will always be here
Alice: 我帮你提着吧
Alice: I'll hold it for you
其他人：没事没事就一个
Others: It's okay, it's just one
Alice:你好白
Alice: You're so fair-skinned
其他人：这个公园好小一眼就望到头了
Others: This park is so small, you can see the end in one glance
Shure:  让我这个美丽的下午突然不美丽了
Shure: This beautiful afternoon suddenly became not so beautiful
Alice: 是的
Alice: Yes
其他人：我们这样走一圈很快就完了
Others: If we walk around like this, we'll be done quickly
Alice:确实
其他人：你今天穿的好那种森系的感觉
Others: You're dressed in such a forest style today
Alice: 森系啊
Alice: Forest style?
其他人：有点像无印良品的那种风格
Others: Kind of like the Muji style
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm
Alice: 其实我平时穿衣服都是嗯花里胡哨的
Alice: Actually, I usually dress in very flashy colors
其他人：哦是吗
Others: Oh, really?
Alice: 就是一一个身上可能有五六颜色那种
Alice: Like, I might have five or six colors on me
其他人：挺好
Others: That's nice
Alice: 这是我为数不多的浅色衣服
Alice: This is one of the few light-colored clothes I have
其他人：热的脸都红了太热了
Others: Our faces are all red, it's so hot
Alice: 你你是在快毕业年级吗
Alice: Are you in your final year?
其他人：我是研一
Others: I'm a first-year grad student
Alice: 研究生了
Alice: A graduate student already
其他人：我看你们还有要给小狗
Others: I see you still need to feed the dog
Alice: 这里面吗
Alice: In here?
其他人：没有就是呃他们拍在群里
Others: No, they just posted it in the group
其他人：有一个隔壁的奶茶店的小狗到啊
Others: There's a dog from the milk tea shop next door